stability AI has a few growing pains in
the recent weeks they found themselves
in multiple controversies and we're
going to look at them in detail today
Yahoo finance rights stability AI the
startup behind stable diffusion raises
101 million US Dollars now I've done
previously a video on stable diffusion
which is the new text to image model
that has been released open source free
for everyone to access and use and I've
done a video on the great things that
people build and are still building with
it it's absolutely amazing the
creativity that comes out of people when
you just give them stuff and I've also
done an interview with Ahmad mustad the
founder of stability AI where he shared
his opinions and an approach to sharing
more so according to him stability ai's
goal is to be what open AI was supposed
to be these are my words not his uh open
AI was supposed to be this decentralized
collaborative thing where everything is
is open and AI is made accessible to
everyone and it's ended up to be an API
provider that you can you know call for
money now stability has made the first
step in releasing stable diffusion to
the World open and as I said it's
Unleashed a big part of creativity
however in recent weeks they found
themselves at the center of multiple
controversies So today we're going to go
over four different instances of these
controversies first stability takes over
the subreddit that's community-led and
the Discord server that's community-led
kicking out all other mods second
stability AI goes after a GitHub user
that provides an alternative web UI to
theirs and accuse them of stealing some
code but the truth is actually no they
stole code from him first or both
actually took code from somewhere else
it's kind of a mess third stability
issues a take down notice for a model on
the hogging face Hub that they claim is
their own intellectual property namely
stable diffusion version 1.5 and later
they take back that takedown notice and
lastly their CIO releases a public
statement about how they think about
open sourcing models and in my opinion
it's very very scary statement so we're
going to go into these things in detail
as always let me know what you think as
with all of these things it's very hard
to actually research all of what
happened and there are conflicting
accounts of things and conflicting
interpretations so take what I say with
a grain of salt look at the stuff
yourself and come to your own
conclusions
[Music]
so first of all we have a story from
analytics India mag that says when
stability AI went rogue on Reddit
Rampage a couple of days ago stability
AI infiltrated the stable diffusion
Community banned some of the users
kicked out the moderators and took over
the subreddit this is some you know
Bungie headline and actually you know
this is this is my thumbnail
Source Reddit I I guess I've posted it
on Reddit I'm not sure but I guess the
com it's a compliment since uh it's a
good thumbnail well this all started
with posts on Reddit from former
moderators saying hello I'm an
ex-moderator of the subreddit and
Discord and I've been here since the
beginning this subreddit was intended to
be unofficial and run by the community
two weeks ago the first moderator was
tricked into giving control of the
subreddit and transferred to stability
stability meaning the company stability
AI all the moderators were also removed
from here and even the one who created
this subreddit was kicked out of the
team and banned now this raised some
eyebrows we also have this statement
from another moderator saying mod here
my side of the story they say they are
on very good terms with stability
they've done a lot for them but they say
I just don't see why I would hide what I
know for any longer they say they were
here from the beginning 50 subscribers
to the subreddit they asked whether they
could help moderate from then on there
were like two moderators of this
subreddit they also made a Discord
server and both of these things quickly
exploded as stable diffusion became
burst into the mainstream at one point
they say official stability staff came
in clearly showed their interest in
making the Discord official so this was
both the Discord and the subreddit were
inofficial were just run by fans and all
of a sudden stability comes in and says
well that's a cool Community you know
can we essentially make this our
official Discord server so far so good
this happens so the real inflection
point seemed to be when they said the
stable diffusion beta program so where
people could actually try out the model
on Discord would be run on my Discord
server the Discord server quickly grew
to 50K members they even got the vanity
link and then they say something like a
few days after which my server got the
verified badge that Discord gives to
official servers weird I thought since I
the owner of the server never asks for
the badge and am not officially
affiliated with stability I can only
imagine a mod asked for it while they
were conversing with Discord pure
speculation though so now this
unofficial Discord that has been sort of
kind of made official by the stability
staff but was still owned by a
non-stability member he's now given sort
of the verified batch like this is like
the blue check mark on Twitter this is
the official server for stable diffusion
or for stability yeah I guess stable
diffusion is more accurate The Story
Goes On saying mere days later it became
clear that PR public relations I guess
did not want me to hold a position that
made me falsely seem like stability
staff I understood and informed them I'd
be fine with giving away ownership but
that not being conventionally possible
since the server has the verified badge
now so once the server is verified you
can't just transfer the server to
someone else this is to prevent abuse
now I would guess the normal way to now
transfer the server would be something
like to go to Discord and to ask them
hey could I transfer that server to
these people yes I verify I really want
to do this I verify they are the true
owners of stability AI the brand for
which this Discord server is the
official Discord server yada yada yada
however that did not happen a few days
later I wake up to see I no longer owned
the Discord server fact I never reached
out to Discord and Discord never reached
out to me so apparently Discord just
kind of transfer the server I guess they
were in contact with stability and
stability made it appear like the two
things are closer than they were
obviously this person was clearly
willing to give up the server and I
guess stability communicated that to
Discord but Discord just didn't follow
their process of actually asking the
person hey do you really want to do that
so they just kind of took away the
server from him and handed it over not
that much of a big deal but like a bit
scary right so apparently later the
ownership was transferred back and
someone that we can assume that is from
stability called cyber bully said the
ownership has been transferred to you
following the post on Reddit since it
was a big issue for you you can now do
the transfer to Imad yourself and also a
message from Discord itself saying yes
indeed there was a mix up and they
should have come to this person and
asked them whether they really wanted to
transfer the Discord and not just take
it away from them so it's kind of
unclear whether Discord themselves found
that they've screwed up and then sought
this cyber bully person just kind of
reacted to that because it just says has
been transferred to you or whether
they've actually initiated it to be
honest this also is it is like a bit
passive aggressive it's not like we're
sorry we clearly screwed up so we're
like well uh since you made a Reddit
post and you know since this is a big
issue it's actually a small issue but
since to you you know you make a big
deal out of it fine Diva right you
cannot transfer it yourself it's very
much the attitude of like oh come on
it's not such a big deal like it kind of
is a big deal there's two levels here
right level one screw up happened
probably by Discord okay we can we we
get it right like this stuff happens but
level two is sort of the the tone which
I don't think is quite appropriate to to
be like uh this top down and then
apparently later without any doing at
all they've taken the Discord server
away again saying hi all apologies for
this we've transferred ownership back to
mod and revisiting our process of
transferring ownership to ensure this
does not happen again all in all it
seems pretty clear the Discord server
should have transferred ownership in one
way or another the process was a bit
dirty and Cyberbully was just kind of
being a dick but the story doesn't end
there moving to the subreddit this mod
says I had taken ownership of the
subreddit a week before since stability
wanted someone more trustworthy to hold
that position then however someone from
stability Security Department contacted
me and asked me to transfer ownership to
actual stability staff given stability
has been awesome to me so far and
promising me great opportunities in the
future I complied did they like it would
be funny if they just used that exact
wording like great opportunities await
you young lad I guess they've said you
know we can do something for you in the
future you've been pretty cool
administrating this as a volunteer they
say promising the original General owner
and other mods to retain a mod position
they never followed through with that
and only invited one person and me back
as a mod without giving them full
permissions that's how we arrive at the
present day I did try to warn them about
holding corporate motivated positions on
a sub that did not seem to phase them
though so that's where the sentence
before came in where they say they
tricked someone into giving them
permissions they essentially came in and
said hey
um we are you know the real deal we
would like to administrate this
subreddit that is about us even though
Reddit is sort of supposed to be in this
sort of fan mode so subreddits are
supposed to be unaffiliated with the
thing they're about because it's
supposed to be community-led but you
know you can all decide that for
yourself essentially they came in and
said we would like to take control here
that's okay the person said yes you're
very cool that's okay if you know we can
stay on as moderators and the other
moderators too they said yes and then
they just didn't so people got a bit
upset about these things but you know
always remember there's probably always
two sides at least two sides to every
story there is a Discord message from
Ahmad himself saying just getting
information now as catching up seems
like we wanted to give mods non-public
data so there was an NDA system in place
and some mods say yay some mods say nay
and he doesn't exactly know what's going
on so far on top of that there's also
something that I just I just heard okay
I I don't have a way to confirm this but
the person the moderator we just heard
from is a miner not of legal age right
now that's not the the rumor the rumor
is that then at some point they actually
got on payroll of stability so that they
would count as an employee so that they
would fall sort of under employee
secrecy and stuff I don't know again I
don't know what happened what is public
is the fact that the moderators were
switched out the moderators that were
are swapped in they did not have long
lasting Reddit accounts they did not
have experience as moderators and it
very much seemed like there was some
sort of Switcheroo happening and
promises made that were then not
fulfilled now all of this does have a
bit of a happy end as David ha actually
joined stability AI as the head of
strategy you may know David ha also from
his username hard Maru on Reddit and
Twitter he's very active he always has
the absolute best prompts for text to
image models I very much enjoy following
him and he is from what I can tell a
very straightforward and trustworthy
person so I'm very happy that someone
like this is in a leading role in such a
kind of new and wild company so he
himself actually on his first day of
work or his second day of work posted a
post in the stable diffusion subreddit
saying yes actually this should go back
to the community he says stability AI is
a young company needs to learn how to
engage on social media he personally
joined the sub earlier this year he
believes that stable diffusion should be
independent and run by the community
stability AI will give up all control of
this sub including mod privileges this
company is built around our community
and want to keep it that way going
forward we will engage with this
community as regular users when we
respond to concerns inquiries or make
new announcements and so ownership was
transferred back to the original
moderators after this as for the Discord
server I believe they are still in
control of that which I guess is fine
since it is actually the official
Discord server so where does that leave
us with all of these stories you can
interpret it in many different ways on
one end of the Spectrum which is very
much where I fall I think what happened
is that stability AI has just kind of
exploded in recent years they have or
Years days weeks right they have just
gotten so much publicity at once they
have had to higher in people they've had
to react fast to things and probably the
culture in this company is also the sort
of decentralized way that they feel the
entire AI World should run so I'm going
to guess that a lot of people with
instability have gotten sort of a lot of
freedom and power very very quickly and
sort of the instructions to just make
things happen and do things and decide
for yourself and be kind of a pirate and
a bit radical right and therefore quick
rash decisions were made which were
probably not in the interest of the
company or the community if they had
thought longer about it so I'm very much
at the end of the spectrum that says
that these are essentially Growing Pains
mixed in a few people that don't really
have experience with their kind of power
and the kind of reach that they have
right now on the other end of the
spectrum you can always of course say
that this is an evil company it's been
an evil company from the start they're
looking to make money they're looking to
control everything can't tell you you
which one is the case I'm just tending
towards one end of the Spectrum which
brings us to the next bit of drama which
is automatic's web UI so automatic one
one one one is a person username on
GitHub on Reddit on 4chan I believe and
they made a web UI for stable diffusion
an alternative to the dream Studio that
is the official web UI by stability Ai
and this is the most extensive
alternative web UI and a lot of people
have been using automatic's web UI for
doing things it's really cool it's just
open you can just download it now there
are some initial issues with this as you
can see right here there is not really a
license to it so even though it's kind
of open it's not really open source at
least not in a sense where we would
actually know how we could use this
stuff but in any case here is a showcase
you can do lots and lots and lots and
lots and lots and lots of stuff so
automatics seem to just have been
scouring the internet for things to do
with these diffusion models and then
incorporating them more and more and
more into the web UI and it ended up
with a lot of features being very usable
and therefore a lot of people used it
now what happens from here is a bit
shady and unclear I've tried to piece
together the timeline and what was very
helpful are some of these summary posts
that exist on Reddit for example in out
of the loop the user t top e has a
lengthy post on what happened and so
does the user symes boy on the stable
diffusion subreddit they have sort of a
step-by-step breakdown a good point to
dive in are a set of Discord messages
apparently from someone named ether that
is from stability AI supposedly at least
from the stable diffusion Discord server
that texted to automatic hello I'm
reaching out to you from the stable
diffusion server in regard to the recent
novel AI leaks now these leaks have been
leaking proprietary material of this
company novel AI novel AI is a company
that is in some way connected to
stability AI either they're just backed
by them with compute they get like early
access to their systems and things like
this so these two are sort of connected
stability and novel AI now novel AI had
apparently been building some features
as closed Source features this is cool
you can do this now this had been leaked
there's been an exploit that allowed
hackers to gain access to proprietary
material by novel AI specifically they
have leaked out some model that novel AI
has been developing That Was Then passed
around the internet now automatic giving
that they have a web UI that a lot of
people use rushed to make the web UI
compatible with the leaked model so they
didn't just incorporate the leaked model
or you know hacked it themselves I guess
who knows but there's no proof they
hacked it themselves they simply made
their web UI compatible with that now in
order to make that compatible they
obviously also had to incorporate some
code now there are multiple different
layers here but let's go on with the
messages it has come to our attention
that some of your recent commits contain
code that could have only been written
by looking at leaked proprietary code
confirmed by a core developer who had
worked on that code we're asking you to
please remove any recent additions
containing that code from your
repository given that this data has been
unlawfully leaked on 4chan and is not
intended to be open source we cannot
align with these actions and have had to
remove your stable Society role within
the server thank you automatic replies
to this the code has been written by me
from scratch loading vae is basics of
Basics and Hyper networks is also a
technique that has been demonstrated law
long ago I do not see why I should
remove those just because leaked code
exists if you want to remove me from
your roles you're free to do so hello by
the way by the way
so again after review and discussion
with our team I've made the decision to
ban you from the stable diffusion server
on the grounds of unethical Community
participation around the recent novel AI
leaks sure whatever alright so now it
sounds like proprietary code from novel
AI has been found in automatics
repository and they asked them to remove
that now in fact there is a tiny bit of
Truth to that as automatic themselves
say right here from line 44 to line 55
is copied verbatim from the novel AI
code base however it's just dead code
it's been there for a total of two
commits and it was removed after that
and it still runs everything as said
they didn't actually refer to these
lines of code when they accuse them of
stealing code but they refer to other
lines of code now comes the kicker this
summary post States however it was soon
pointed out that this code the one they
accused automatic of stealing predated
novel ai's in implementation and was
open source making automatic innocent of
thievery it was then pointed out that
novel AI was using Code taken from
automatic that was not open source
making them the actual thieves in this
situation so they started out accusing
automatic of stealing their code turns
out they've actually both taken that
code from some open source repository
and since automatic doesn't have any
sort of Open Source license technically
the code from the web UI isn't open
source and they've actually taken code
from that repository and yeah so
ultimately they're in violation of the
license they blamed it on an intern
however the pull of this code on GitHub
had the name of a senior programmer
within novel AI casting doubts on the it
was an intern excuse oh it was an intern
of course of course it was an intern
sure sure I mean even if it was an
intern right they are out there
attacking in like an independent
volunteer creator that sort of keeps
half of the stable diffusion interact
actions of the world going I guess like
a paid intern is still Laden with more
responsibility than some sort of
volunteer that just puts their stuff on
GitHub yet they have no problem
attacking that volunteer yet when it
comes to them it's like oh oh it was an
oh ah I mean
so automatic was exiled from the Discord
server removed from the pinned guide on
the stable diffusion subreddit I'm gonna
guess that's when the company still had
control over it and just kind of been
treated at the side now it's not all
clear-cut as I said automatic had
actually copied code even though it was
it was dead code and it was removed
right away and they weren't talking
about that code but still it's not super
clear-cut and also if you know the
company probably wants to take a stance
against including sort of leaked
material into web uis because they don't
want to be seen that they want to comply
with that by having this in sort of the
the pinned sidebar you know if you're a
company money and your proprietary
property is out there somewhere leaked
and you kind of want to prohibit that
but then you have like a link to a web
UI that says here is how you can use the
leaked thing just kind of looks but so I
can understand why they sort of want to
distance themselves but yeah no they
could just say like you know we don't
support the inclusion of sort of the
leaked model into that web UI they
didn't have to go super hard after him
especially especially if it if it was
wrong right if it then turned out no
actually they both just took open source
code and they had actually stolen from
automatic in any case later a discussion
post was opened on automatics GitHub
repository saying hi automatic this is a
mod from stability AI hosting here as
this is where you spend most of your
time this is an apology apologize for
the manner which my actions hurt the
hurt they may have caused should have
reached out to you and talked to you
before and it's it's just like it's it's
an apology it's a apology saying we're
sorry about the this however the the
account it I mean it's just called e
stability and on the Reddit post that
references this apology automatic
comments saying like you guys are a
little bit gullible and when asked to
explain they say the apology is a joke
post by a random person who made a fake
account and my response to it is also a
joke so the response was this come on a
mod you already apologized in person
over the tea yesterday there is no need
for this so This apparently is sarcasm
now I have heard but also couldn't
confirm that emad actually said that yes
this was indeed him and this was indeed
a real sincere apology and to this day I
I don't know whether it's true or not so
I can neither confirm nor deny that as
they say in court I guess and I do
believe with the sort of reversion back
to community-led subreddit automatics
web UI is again a pinned link there
however again you can ask yourself you
know which side of the spectrum are you
on is this an evil company that sees a
competing web UI and just wants to take
out the Creator because it's become more
popular than their own web UI or again
is this a company where too many people
have gotten too much power and being
told you know just do things we'll do
things in a decentralized way we're kind
of radical so just do stuff and they
just go about it with bit too much force
and a bit too little thought uh it
happens you know I can tell stories of
this again I'm gonna be leaning on the
side of just a bit more chaos than just
deliberate evilness given also from the
fact that they've never before accused
automatic of any sort of bad behavior or
anything like this like they weren't
openly hostile to automatic beforehand
so there's no indication that they were
unhappy that this web UI was gaining a
lot of traction now again you could be
saying well this is all strategic and so
on I'm not sure never attribute to
malice what you can attribute to
incompetence but now we get to the the
last bit and that's the release of
stable diffusion 1.5 stable diffusion is
a model that has seen a number of
updates in sort of recent weeks and
stable diffusion 1.5 is the next
iteration in that line now as you can
see here it was released on the hugging
face hubby not stability AI but by
Runway ml now stable diffusion even
though stability AI sort of puts
themselves behind it it's actually a
conglomeration by many people building
on Research that has been open sourced
and published before all the code it's
sort of like a Melting Pot of different
things that exist and then maybe some
engineering tricks on top of that so
with these open source things it's hard
to say who actually owns what now
apparently stability had wanted to hold
back version 1.5 until they are ready to
release it whereas Runway ml which is a
company that makes creative tools makes
a image editors and video editors that
are based on AI has one and wanting to
release this so they have released it
and after they've released it stability
AI has requested a takedown of this
published model characterizing it as a
leak of their IP IP being intellectual
property not Internet Protocol in this
case so to this takedown request Runway
ml had actually decided to officially
communicate on this discussion thread
saying Chris here CEO and co-founder of
Runway since our founding in 2018 we've
been on a mission to empower anyone to
create the impossible we're excited to
share this newest version of stable
diffusion so that we can continue
delivering our mission this version of
stable diffusion is a continuation of
the original high resolution image
synthesis with latent diffusion models
work that we created and published and
now more commonly referred to as stable
diffusion so stable diffusion comes from
a line of published research and the
researchers that had been working on
this paper at least partially are now
part of Runway ml stable diffusion is an
AI model developed by Patrick Esser from
Runway and Robin rombach from LMU Munich
the research and code behind stable
diffusion was open sourced last year the
model was released under the creative ml
open rail M license we confirm there has
been no breach of Ip as flagged and we
thank stability AI for the compute
donation to retrain the original model
so essentially this is like a it's it's
like also formulated a bit passive
aggressively here but I think Chris has
every reason to do so essentially saying
that nope all the code has existed we
actually authored that code or part of
us author that code it's all open source
it's all there the model that we've
retrained is actually under an open
source license so absolutely no claim to
IP can be laid here to stability saying
that they essentially just provided the
compute to retrain the original model
and simply providing the compute does
not not make them the owner of the IP
now I am not a lawyer this is not legal
advice I don't know what the exact legal
situation is right here but it does make
a lot of sense to me that they
essentially say like wait you know all
of this stuff is open source so we can
retrain this stuff just as much as you
can and it's not like they have
retrained you know two things it's not
like Runway ML and stability have both
worked on a version 1.5 or something it
seems like stability was the compute
Giver two Runway to actually develop the
official 1.5 of stable diffusion and
then as far as I can tell from the
conversations and speculation around it
again this is all speculation it was
such that stability wanted to kind of
hold back that release while Runway
wanted to release it and in the end I
guess Runway decided let's release it
because you know legally there's nothing
they can do side note see this edited
four days ago a lot of these things are
edited including like the official thing
right here now this says edit right here
but for the other ones like I don't like
what's what are the edits I can't see
like as much as it's cool to have public
discussions on the hogging face huh I
really need to see how they edited stuff
because you know otherwise how are you
gonna know what happened like I'll just
insert like some empty posts every now
and then and then later I can go on and
edit them to say anything I want well in
any case uh there is a lot of discussion
following right here however stability
never officially said anything here in
this open discussion however as Julian
says in the original Post in the edit
stability legal team reached out to
hugging face reverting the initial
takedown request therefore we close this
thread so the model stays up and running
under Runway ml as a stable diffusion
version 1.5 and again you can ask
yourself big evil company that is trying
to you know make money therefore keep
the models to themselves not wanting
someone else to release them maybe on
the other hand was this kind of a rash
decision to issue this takedown request
when clearly I guess they didn't really
have claims and even if it like makes
them look really really really bad uh
yes on on that too so again I don't
really know I also don't exactly know
what happened right here stability AI
certainly has Associated themselves
heavily with the name stable diffusion
but to what degree stable diffusion is
actually a product of stability AI
whether they have rights or not for
giving compute how much they've actually
worked on it all of this is quite in
transparent on top of that a lot of this
stuff if not all is actually open source
the code is open source the data is open
source the models that serve as
checkpoints maybe are open source and
therefore you can also ask yourselves
well if I take stable diffusion 1.5 and
to train it for a bit more can I just
call it stable diffusion 1.6 is there a
trademark or something on it is this now
a public word all of these questions are
completely open as I can say in none of
these situations stability AI has
necessarily made the popular choice
whether it's like an evil or a good
choice that's you know a question that
you might want to ask I lean towards it
was more speed incompetence and pirate
mentality that sort of made them screw
up a couple of times rather than
evilness however now comes the actual
scary part so this is a post from Daniel
Jeffries who is the CIO of stable
diffusion the post is called why the
future of Open Source AI is so much
bigger than stable diffusion 1.5 and why
it matters to you this is a post in part
justifying why they wanted to keep to
hold back the release of stable
diffusion 1.5 Daniel Jeffries is as I
said the CIO and the post is very much
written from the perspective of
stability AI saying all of it all the
time saying we you know we have taken a
step back at stability AI so this is
definitely speaking from the perspective
of the company and not just a personal
opinion now if you've watched my
interview with him mod Ahmad had very
much the attitude of yeah we'll just
release the stuff you know if people
want to do weird things with it then so
be it right in fact the tool is only
useful if you can do good and bad things
with it and you know I think the last
weeks have demonstrated clearly the
benefits of releasing these things to
the public clearly much more good has
come out of this than bad has come out
of it and the bad that would have been
prevented by you know putting the model
behind an API I'm not sure that that
much bad has been prevented in any case
guess why guess what the reasoning of
Daniel Jeffries is why they wanted to
hold back stable diffusion 1.5 we've
heard from regulators and the general
public that we need to focus more
strongly on security to ensure that
we're taking all the steps possible to
make sure that people don't use stable
diffusion for illegal purposes or
hurting people yes hurting people it's
like completely open AI again open AI is
starting out we want to be open we want
to democratize we want to bring this to
everyone and then they're like ah but we
need to make sure it's safe like it
can't be saved the definition of a
useful tool means you can use it which
means you can also use it for bad if you
can use it for anything at all it's
possible to be used for bad and it's the
same mentality the mentality is we know
what's good for you so we keep this to
ourselves and once we have determined
what's you know that it's appropriate
the new plebs you can have it and we're
going to form foundations to make it
seem like we're a non-profit open AI is
ruled by by a non-profit I mean the
company itself is limited profit and
it's you know a hold held by a
non-profit and we are going to form
Committees of experts and and you know
everyone can take no like no it's the
exact same thing again we know what's
good for you we are the Elite we know
and you know you don't so we can't trust
you to make these decisions because
think of the children the blog post is
also filled with statements such as we
also won't stand by quietly when other
groups leaked the model in order to draw
some quick press to themselves while
trying to wash their hands of
responsibility that tell me this doesn't
sound exactly like open AI like or like
the journalists that came after this
model and sentences like we are
committed to open source at our very
core like no you're not you're you're
not like if if you believe that you
first do things and then only once
you've determined it's good for the
plebs then you release it you're not
committed to open source at your very
core you are not of the attitude that
people should have access to the tools
and should have self-determination of
what to do with them because before long
you will discover in fact that there's
not possible to release a model that is
safe enough the only possibility is in
fact to put it behind an API and filter
the queries and filter the outputs and
don't let people put bad words into that
thing and you know have terms of
services that prohibit people from doing
anything at all except building a
rainbow world around the model where
nothing bad ever happens and at that
point it will become useless lastly
again you have the choice of believing
obviously stability it was just all the
trick and they're exactly the same as
open AI because clearly one of their
senior officials says so the other
possibility that I want gonna suggest to
you is very much also the same as I said
before this thing grew it grew very
quickly and it is very well possible
that Ahmad had to hire a lot of people
including this person who has a
completely opposite opinion of anything
that stability Ai and open AI in its
real sense stands for and has just kind
of let these people run loose a little
bit and all we can hope for is that
either he gets a better grip on these
people or that the community steps up
and essentially makes Daniel Jeffries
and similar people have a change of
hearts and if there is a third
possibility then that is that Regulators
are making so much pressure on these
people that they're essentially forced
into this track well in this case I can
only hope that you know stability AI
finds themselves in a situation where
they don't comply where they say no we
are going to release stuff and we're not
just going to lay down flat when the
European in Union or California comes in
and enacts regulation just because
people can do bad stuff with things
we'll find a different way of
Distributing these things we'll find a
different way of getting people access
and we are not going to just stop
innovating and stop releasing and we are
not going to centralize power and
putting everything behind an API until
it's squeaky clean or no longer useful
remember what openai said about gpt2 not
3 gpt2 They delayed the release of the
model due to its potential of abuse now
we look back now and we know that this
is completely bogus and no there is no
way gpt2 has any serious potential for
abuse and in fact no one has abused it
there has been not really any
significant demonstration of its abuse
now you can say good Fair open AI didn't
know at the moment but also that was the
point of gpt2 was the point point in
time where the strategy was invented of
claiming that due to security concerns
we're not going to release this to the
public we're going to keep this for
ourselves until we tested it and now
gpt2 can be found on the hugging face
Hub but after a couple of years after
all of this I don't know what the
conclusion is I don't know what to tell
you what I can say is that I really
really hope that stability will get back
on track and regain its commitment and
its outlook on being open being
Community Driven being decentralized and
yeah releasing their stuff now I'm not
saying they have any obligation to do so
they're a company they're absolutely
entitled to just say nope actually we
want to make money and we build our
closed Source models like that's fine
but it's just not in compliance with
what they claim to be in a very much
hope that there is someone on this
planet that is like they claim to be
open decentralized end sharing whatever
happens will keep a very close eye on
this and I'll see you next time bye
[Music]